really be able to connect to people who
don't look like you who have kinky hair
who have dark skin uh and to see
yourself in them and it's whiteness that
prevents that ibram X kendi is sort of
the great um he in some ways I hate to
give the guy too much credit but he's
kind of the architect of Every Which Way
that woke has infected all of our
cultural institutions and especially at
a at a television level and uh here he
is this guy's racist this guy is a
racist mfer that's all he is he has no
true understanding of Freedom or America
or anything else but what does that lead
to if you're just like a Neo rist and
you happen to be black you're going to
get a gig at Netflix and they're going
to pay you a whole bunch of money to put
out some racist programming for guilty
white people so here's ibram kendi
getting a giant Round of Applause at a
Netflix screaming uh screening uh of his
new show while of course demonizing
white people I guess that was just a
bonus but take a look I don't think uh
White uh people worldwide have really
reckoned with how much their own
personal identity is shaped by
constructions of
whiteness and and how
much um that construction of
whiteness uh
prevents uh white people from uh
connecting to humanity in other words uh
recognizing that uh when you when you
recognize that you are part and parcel
of humanity in other words you're not
over Humanity right uh it it allows you
to really be able to connect to people
who don't look like you who have kinky
hair who have dark skin uh and to see
yourself in them
and it's whiteness that prevents that
right and and when you're not able to
see
yourself uh in other human
beings that creates all sorts of
problems um but not just societal
problems personal
problems that that I think hopefully
this this this film and this work will
will liberate those folks from so I I
think it's this liberate it's liberating
all the way around right it it you know
I think it it will liberate you know
really all of us because
you know we've all been told a lie about
ourselves and other
people oh oh my god oh that is incred
first off everything he said there was
complete epic bull also I'm pretty sure
he culturally appropriated his
dreadlocks from the Predator uh also
Connor I'd like to ask you because you
are our representative you're our main
white you're our whitest you guys are
both white but you're but you're our
main whitest person here uh he said that
whiteness prevents you from connecting
to
humanity would you do that would you say
that's applicable to you yeah like
you're a pretty nice guy people like
Connor everybody loves Connor you've
been unable to connect with Humanity due
to your whiteness it's it's all just
like they literally put words together
and then a bunch of guilty morons pay
them to do it to put it on oh my God I
should connect with my human I'm white
what am I going to
do